it is a big day today or yesterday was a
big day
uh donald trump conceded the election to
joe biden now i'm not going to click
bait you guys
donald trump did not say i concede to
joe biden that is not something donald
trump is likely to ever say but what
donald trump did say yesterday is
listen i'm still suing people but my
administration
is going to move forward and allow the
formal transition to take place
for now this is donald trump and this is
the closest we may ever
get to a concession from him he's not
saying he lost he's not saying
biden won he's still going to file
lawsuits but he
is allowing the transition to start
which frees up
money for joe biden to start the
transition and he reportedly did this
after being told by
close confidants including his chief of
staff mark meadows
it's time to start moving on there is no
path there's really nothing else it is
time to start moving on now recall
that donald trump was holding up the
transition um
that was emily murphy from the gsas to
sort of formally put in place
this is the general services
administration
they didn't start the process emily
murphy is a trump administration
official
trump had not directed her to start this
process because donald trump hadn't
conceded and the pressure
continued building and finally after
weeks yesterday donald trump tweeted i
want to thank emily murphy at gsa for
her steadfast dedication and loyalty to
our country
she has been harassed threatened and
abused
and i do not want to see this happen to
her her family or employees of gsa
our case strongly continues we will keep
up the good fight and i believe we will
prevail
no you won't nevertheless in the best
interest of our country
i am recommending that emily and her
team do what needs to be done with
regard to
initial protocols and i have done i have
told my team to do the same
so for donald trump this
is admitting defeat this is the
concession
nothing else now needs to happen nothing
else needed to happen
even without this even without the
formal transition joe biden would become
president on january 20th but now
there is simply nothing else and donald
trump says he will keep fighting
he says he still thinks he won he's even
saying he thinks he will prevail
but he is allowing the process to start
now on the other end of this
emily murphy wrote a letter to the biden
campaign
and it is just comically unprofessional
and self-serving um it is all about her
which i guess runs in the trump
administration emily murphy wrote that
all the media reports about her are
wrong she was not acting politically
she did nothing incorrect she has to
ascertain the apparent results of the
presidential election
not impose the president-elect on the
country
she points out she doesn't certify the
winner
she doesn't pick the winner there were
legal challenges and i have to tell you
guys
this is all complete and utter nonsense
she
claims she can't do anything until
results are certified that's not true
in every election the results are not
really
truly fully certified until the electors
vote in december
and yet somehow in 2016 gsa
started the transition in november in
2012 there was no
transition but the results were were as
far as the gsa was concerned clear
within days of the election same thing
in 2008 same thing in the year 2000 this
is
absolute and total nonsense the whole
letter that she wrote
is a self-aggrandizing mess which you
can read in full if you're so inclined
i don't find it necessary to give you
the full contents of the letter today
bottom line is this uh donald trump
had close aides go to him and say it's
time
we have to move on the this there's
really nothing else that we can do
donald trump without saying i lost fair
and square
without saying joe biden will be
president he said
go ahead and now she says emily murphy
go ahead and uh this is
this is it this entire interim period
will be an asterisk in the history books
of one of the most dystopian
authoritarian attempts
to steal the election it will obviously
be unsuccessful
we knew weeks ago that it would be
unsuccessful
and now with the start of the formal
transition 6.3 million dollars is freed
up for joe biden's transition
another million is freed up for what's
called a pointy
orientation bing bang boom things are
moving ahead
fully and completely at this point in
time this is the closest thing we are
ever going to see to a concession
from donald trump trump has been urged
even by many republicans to start this
transition more formally
it's not clear donald trump is really
listening to those people
it seems some of his closest aides came
to him and said
you've got to do it you really should do
it and it is happening and we are one
step closer
uh to moving on from this national
nightmare of a complete and total fiasco
and the questions that remain
are really um uh sort of academic
questions right
what will donald trump do between now
and january 20th
will we see him return to the public eye
in any capacity
today he'll be doing some kind of
thanksgiving
turkey ceremony or something like that
with melania will he ever take questions
again will he attend the inauguration
will he ever invite joe biden to the
white house we don't have the answers to
these questions
the the answers are largely irrelevant
to the broader priorities of the country
at this time
joe biden is moving forward he continues
to make cabinet selections
and that's what i want to talk about
next because this is really important
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee they're having a huge
short lasting black friday sale
right now when you use my link which
gives you up to fifty percent off
four sigmatics mushroom coffee is
organic fair trade
single origin arabica coffee with
both lions maine and chaga mushrooms
chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system
in peer reviewed studies i've been
drinking four sigmatic coffee lately it
tastes
nothing like mushrooms it just tastes
like delicious
coffee it's really easy on the stomach
doesn't give you a jittery feeling or a
midday crash and
if you try it yourself you will see why
they have over twenty thousand
five star reviews and best of all if you
don't
love it you'll get all your money back
because they stand behind their product
you really have nothing to lose by
giving it a try their incredible black
friday sale is offering you up to 50
percent off plus an additional 10
percent off sale
items but only when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman
the link is right underneath this video